[Music]
from the moment I told the Baudelaires
their parents perished in a terrible
fire they've had adventures in all sorts
of exotic locales I've just dropped them
off at boarding school I know all about
you you've been sent to guardian after
Guardian and adversity has always
followed I'm afraid that you'll have to
live in a small tin shack craps horse
Jacques crabs
her parents were a part of something
might be the reason all these terrible
things keep happening
Count Olaf is still looking for us
does this seem like a nightmare because
that's the effect I was going for
who is this man that's cut off in his
guise just in the middle of a scheme to
our fortune what sane man would disguise
himself four times in a row we lost our
parents in a fire we lost our parents as
well we've seen a lot of things we can't
explain it's like a spy boss
there's a secret room part of a mystery
we'll never be free until we figure out
what it is we have eyes everywhere and
we are always watching
I uh we don't have much time I think
I've got it
no please this time I have no mercy I
will be satisfied with just your fortune
I will obliterate you the cruelest way
ambassador for the camaraderie of this
hospital is really inspiring
need to keep
I wish you luck
[Music]
and I think you're going to need it this
episode in the lives the Baudelaires is
about to get much much worse
how's work sunny laughter you type like
a one-year-old
[Music]
you